- The absolute pressure, P,
in a fluid of density, rho,
I know this looks like a lowercase p,
but this is the Greek letter rho,
which we typically use for density,
at a given depth, h, can be found
with the above equation,
where capital P, with the
little subscript of this,
I guess P sub zero, or maybe instead O,
but it looks like a zero,
P sub zero is atmospheric pressure
and g is gravitational acceleration.
Which of the following
is the correct expression
for the depth in terms
of the absolute pressure,
atmospheric pressure, fluid density,
and gravitational acceleration?
So essentially, what we want to do
is we want to solve for depth.
We want to solve for h.
So let's see if we can do that.
So we have P is equal to P sub,
I'll call this P sub zero,
plus rho times g times h.
Now to solve for h, I'd
at least want to isolate
this term that contains
h on the right-hand side.
So let me subtract P sub
zero from both sides.
So subtract P sub zero,
subtract P sub zero.
And then on the left-hand side,
I have capital P minus
P, capital P sub zero
is equal to, those are
going to cancel out.
You're going to have rho times g times h.
And now to solve for h,
I can divide both sides by rho times g.
So let's do that.
Let's divide this side by rho times g.
And let's divide this side
by rho times, rho times g.
Rho times g divided by rho
times g is just going to be one.
And we get h is equal to
this thing right over here.
We're going to say h is
equal to capital P minus
capital P sub zero over rho times g.
And that is the first
choice right over there.